Farrah Moan: Look at
this little baby girl!
Hi guys! I'm Farrah Moan
from "RuPaul's Drag Race"
season nine and All Stars four.
I am here with...
Jake Gabbard: Jake.
Farrah: Jake! And he wants to try
and become a drag queen today.
So we're gonna have some red wine,
and we are gonna get all up in this mug
with just whatever we could
find at the drugstore,
and see what happens.
So...
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Farrah: We're gonna start first
with this foundation stick.
So, I want you to grab this.
Jake: Okay.
Farrah: And look in your little mirror,
Jake: Alright.
Farrah: And just smear it
all over your face.
Jake: All over?
Farrah: Yup. Make sure
to really concentrate it
on those parts.
Jake: Alright. It's
really thick, that's okay?
Farrah: Oh, this is drag, babe.
You don't have to do it too
heavy, because you will blend,
but I just wanna do this
because it looks satisfying.
Oh yeah, cover that beard.
Now, you're gonna take
your little beauty sponge.
Jake: Okay.
Jake: And just work it in?
Farrah: Lemme feel it.
Yup, it's perfect.
Now, what you wanna do is just...
Until it's evenly spread
all over the face.
Jake: Okay.
Farrah: Faster, harder! And
not down, don't do downward.
Pat in.
Jake: Pat it in, okay.
Oh, I see.
Farrah: Pat in.
Jake: I'm very new to this.
Farrah: Have you ever done drag before?
Jake: No! When I was high
school I went as Marilyn Monroe
for a project, so I did a
little lipstick and a wig.
And that was the extent of it.
Farrah: Lipstick and a wig!
Jake: That was my drag experience.
Farrah: Your memoir.
Jake: Yeah.
Farrah: Yeah, don't be afraid to really
just beat that foundation in there, baby.
You are clearly a man.
And we are going to make
you somewhat of a woman.
Jake: You're gonna have
to work some magic.
Farrah: See how it's just very fast?
And then, oh my God, look,
your beard is gone! Wow.
That's wild.
Jake: Nice.
Farrah: None of us on
our first time doing drag
didn't have 5 o'clock shadow.
In fact, mine might be
growing in right now.
Jake: You're supposed to...
Farrah: Oh, don't forget
your little pink ears.
Jake: Oh, I gotta do my ears too?
Farrah: Yass! Babe!
Of course.
At this point, the next step
would be a cream contour.
Oh my God, look! Drag!
So you always wanna get the man out.
So like, chisel the jaw,
get that little cheekbone,
contour that forehead, get so girly.
So the line here gets
rid of the double chin,
and like, chisels everything.
Jake: Nice.
Farrah: The line here
hollows out your cheekbones
and kinda gives your cheeks some shape,
and kind of creates the
illusion of a protrusion.
A protrusion illusion?
Jake: I like it.
Farrah: Yeah, it kind of
tricks the world into thinking
you have cheekbones.
Jake: I already see the points happening.
Farrah: Yeah, you see it!
Do you feel like a queen yet?
Jake: I'm to feel like a little...
Farrah: Queenie?
Jake: Tingly a little bit, yeah. I get it.
Farrah: Oh my God, it's happening!
You're gonna just take this little,
and just blend it like that.
Is that a woman?
My God, I feel so proud!
Are you gonna be my first drag daughter?
Jake: Sure! What does that mean?
What are the responsibilities
of a drag daughter?
Farrah: Oh well, the drag mother has
all the responsibilities, clearly.
Jake: Oh.
Farrah: What's your drag name gonna be?
Jake: What should my drag name be?
Farrah: Well, if you were my daughter,
since I'm Farrah Moan,
I've always wanted a little
baby girl named Hora Moan.
Jake: Hora Moan! You heard it here first.
Okay, so cue lower third,
I am now Farrah Moan's
drag daughter, Hora Moan.
Farrah: Hora Moan.
Jake: In the flesh.
Farrah: Okay, next we're gonna
set your face with powder.
Relax that forehead or else
you're gonna permanently
put those creases in.
Too late.
Jake: I'm a stressed...
Farrah: Oh, Hora.
You're just a baby girl!
Look at this little baby girl!
Next, we're gonna go in
with some contour again
over the cream, because, if you notice,
when you put that powder on,
it kind of has some pigment to it,
so it takes away a little
bit of the contour.
You can also have a
meltdown and just, like,
like not finish and just wipe it all off,
then stay inside.
If I have a bad...
Jake: This drag queen is
staying in her castle.
Farrah: Castle. Like, her
one bedroom apartment.
Jake: Yeah. Studio.
Farrah: Studio for sure!
Our next step is a good old
liquid liner, and you know what,
Hora Moan, this doesn't get any easier.
Like, I have been doing
drag for seven years now,
and it's still hard, and
I still hold my breath,
and I still get very deep, deep,
deep anxiety from doing this.
Okay, so relax your eyes
and kind of go like this,
like you're really high.
Jake: Okay.
Farrah: And inside of dragging the liner,
just move your head.
Jake: Ohhh.
Farrah: Yeah.
That's what helps me.
Oh, oh no, you're doing it on the bottom?
This is for the top!
This is the cat eye!
Jake: I don't know!
Farrah: This is the
signature Moan cat eye.
Jake: Oh my gosh, I am sorry.
Farrah: Listen kids, you're
all gonna look like this
when you first start, and it's fine!
Because eventually, you
go from this to this.
Oh my God you're doing so good!
Here, let's let it dry a little bit.
Oh that looks great, babe.
Jake: Thank you.
Farrah: You're doing a great job.
Do you want a little sip?
Jake: Yes please, thank you.
Jake: Mm! Okay. Oo, that's yummy.
Farrah: Bartender, can we get some more
when you're available?
Okay.
Now we're gonna stick
these f*cking lashes on.
Normally when you put
these on, you wanna, like,
trim a little bit so
that it matches your eye,
but today we are creating
a different fantasy.
Now I don't trust you to
try and do this yourself,
because you can glue your eye shut.
Oh sh*t!
Jake: Oh yeah. I see.
Farrah: Yeah, you can feel the fantasy?
Do you feel like a woman?
Jake: Yeah.
Yup, it's there.
Farrah: See, the thing about
fake eyelashes is it's, like,
kryptonite to straight men.
Oh my God, so when did you
come out of the closet?
Jake: I'm actually straight.
Farrah: While your eyes are
closed, keep them closed,
keep them closed, we're gonna
put some lipstick on you.
Yeah! Oh God, what brand? Oh.
Oh my God! Look at this
little baby girl, Hora Moan!
You look just like me.
It's crazy.
Jake: Just little baby Hora Moan.
Farrah: Very, very annoyed
that she had to be born,
but very thankful for the
opportunity to inspire.
Okay.
Jake: We'll make it work.
Farrah: This is a little bit MySpace.
Okay. Look.
Jake: Oh! I dig it!
Farrah: Don't you?
You look so pretty!
Oh my God! Oh my God.
Okay, serve us some
face. Serve us some face.
Do a little.
Yes! Give it! Hora Moan!
Looking sickening! Looking gorg!
Looking like a woman!
And no one can tell her
differently even with some
lipstick on her teeth!
Jake: Oh my God.
Farrah: Do you feel it?
Jake: I feel it! I feel...
It's pretty funny to look at.
I look like a...
Farrah: Girl!
Like a drag Reba McEntire or something.
Farrah: Oh work!
Like, oh my God, no.
Kelly Osbourne.
Jake: Yes!
Farrah: When she was a problematic teen?
Jake: Yes. 2002 Kelly Osbourne.
Farrah: We stan.
Jake: Yeah.
Farrah, thank you so much for showing me
how to use all this makeup.
I had no idea how to do any of
it. Now I feel so confident.
Farrah: And look, for your
first time ever using it,
I'm actually very impressed.
Like, it took me a very
long time to, like,
figure out what all
this... I didn't even know
that you could set your face with powder
for like the first year.
I was just shiny as hell.
Yeah, but the straight boys loved it.
But I'm so happy I got
to do this with you,
and I hope that even
though you are straight,
you are going to continue on
with this legacy of my name.
Jake: I will.
Farrah: Hora Moan.
Jake: I will wear your name proudly.
Farrah: Maybe one day you'll
be on "RuPaul's Drag Race."
I'm giving you two thumbs up.
Honestly, I am so proud of you.
You look gorgeous!
Jake: Well thank you.
What do you think?
See the hair is on point.
Jake: Thank you.
The makeup is on point.
Charisma, I assume, is on point.
Jake: Always.
I'll give this a thumbs up.
This look is crazy!
It looks good, overall.
Good job, Jake.
Jake: Thank you.
I give Hora Moan a big thumbs up.
Jake: My name is Hora Moan.
Hora Moan?
I love it.
Jake: Thanks.
Thumbs up, for sure.